it was the perfect husband who didn't
till death do us part kind of as your
pick why aren't you happy as I do you
think Mike is gonna be happy I don't
want to have children right now and you
keep pushing it I just want my wife all
to myself
hi I'm Matt Alexis we live next door
I'm making this prank pack tonight order
to join us
just stop staring at me
I'm sorry
I'm getting out of here don't forget to
cut off the lights inside the alarm
didn't even follow you I'm smarter than
that
I know I'm sorry Alice
[Music]
to death do us part remember
why don't you lie to me Madison
saw in the past daddy's here
oh one that make you feel safe
[Music]
I work very hard to provide this life
Madison
I paid the bills I provide everything is
that not good at all thank you it's good
enough what about what I've won what
about me what about what I want this is
ridiculously selfish of me again you
need to watch your tone you're such a
coward you are a coward you are a liar
don't okay me calm down I'm not gonna
calm down do not tell me to calm down I
do everything for you I do everything I
put my job for you I sit here and I cook
and I clean I love my father for you I
treat you like a king as you should as
you should that is your job be a wife as
your husband I deserved more respect
than you're showing me right now you are
not my husband
you